Uh, Hey guys,
I work in a corporate setting for a company that sells tools that may or may not
be branded with the color orange. The other day,
I was telling my coworker who I have a friendship outside of work, uh,
a story I made up. Let's just say it had to do with midgets and docking.
The thing that Gilbert does, my boss happened to walk by.
I'm not sure if you heard me or not.
Should I be worried that I'll get in trouble?
And do you guys every worry about the things you say that are taken?
The things that you say are taken at face value?
Oh my God, this guy, should this person be worried that he was talking about,
listen, listen guy, what's his name? Uh,
C money to bring back the idea of the context of your heart. You see money,
see money. I was never going to share.
I was never going to share what I'm about to share. Then I'm going to share it.
I'm going to show up with share it. Um, because I was talking to my therapist,
you know, about, you know, I was telling her about, you know,
the things that I talk about on the podcast and she's like, you know,
but that thing that you just said, isn't true. And I go, yeah,
I know I'm in fact,
it's so embarrassing to say most of the things I say, you know what I mean?
In podcasts over my career. Yeah. Is based either in, you know,
some truth or they're complete and utter lies, but it's like,
you know, it, you know, podcasting is a medium. And when you're telling a story,
you know, it's like, you know,
you have to mold it or you have to add,
or you have to subtract, you know, by playing, telling a story.
Like I admit, as.
Mike Bisping says, don't let the truth get in.
A ride. So, um, I'm going to say, you know,
I say that I was molested by a guy with down syndrome. Don't you do this to me.
You better be real. I don't, but you guys don't know the truth. The truth is,
is that I think I wasn't molested, but he definitely didn't have down syndrome.
You know what I mean? Put you, you say I know, but I know I can, I,
now I can never say this again, but it's like, you throw in the, you know,
you know, because you have to stand when I was like, you know,
first doing this kind of thing.
I did it New York and I did Opie and Anthony. Right. And if you're,
you're on a podcast with Jim Norton, you know, Greg Geraldo, Patricia Neil,
all these hard hitters back in the day, you know, I'm my life as it is.
Isn't shocking enough. Yeah. Yeah. Right. It's like,
what can I do? You know what I mean,
to beat these guys into shocking them and
helping them and whatnot. Right. So I would go in,
in podcast and just make up or exaggerate and whatnot.
Like I tell another story that I poke a director in the stomach
and I call him fatty. Right. Please be true. It is true.
But it didn't happen to me.
It didn't happen to me. I stole it from another, my friend, Mike. Right.
I just finished. Let me see. So then, um, you know,
it's difficult to say, you know, and,
but like a lot of things are true too. Like for instance,
the things that we talked about today, right. We saw those movies. Yeah. Right.
We saw the two movies we talked about, you know, we watched you pu yeah.
You know, I did dangle a $20 bill in front of Abby and go, are you drooling?
I mean, that didn't happen. Right. But what I'm saying is, is that God, yeah,
thank God. But like, what I'm saying is, is that bad, but not that bad,
but when you're going back into, you know, history and it supposedly went in,
in this medium, it's like, you know, people take everything you say,
so literally the story, right. You just can't do it.
Oh my God. So when we, um, even before I met you, um,
when I would either listen to you on like your radio appearances,
or even when we,
I think we had only gone out on one date and I listened to all your stuff on
like DVD ASA,
I never in for one second that I ever think that you were
not in performance mode. Like I never thought for one second that, Oh yeah,
that man really did that.
If I really believe that I would have never given you the time.
Yeah. That's the truth. Yeah. She doesn't love you,
but it's true. Right.
It's like when I listened to people or any comics,
even before being in this world at all, growing up, like,
isn't that what the, the, the assume that isn't,
that the assumption of like a sane person to think they're performers they're
gunna tell some grandiose, like half-truths. Yeah.
Like, I don't know. That's just the way I took it,
because if I truly believed all of your stories, Bobby,
like we would not have even gone on a date. So like, when it comes to this guy,
we should answer his question is, um,
that relationship with you and your friend, like in a professional setting,
like it is, it is, you know, you know him outside of work.
That's like a private conversation you had like, theoretically in my head,
it shouldn't get you in trouble.
Well, you shouldn't tell the story. Did he tell the story at work? The kid?
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, listen, he was saying it like with a friend when I'm like,
when I'm in a corporate environment and sometimes I am right.
Like if I'm like, you know, like when I did splitting up together with Oliver,
Hudson, him and I would be like on set and eat, like,
we'd bring something up and that we want to get explicit with him.
And he would look at each other, we'll get coffee afterwards and talk about it.
Like, we won't do it there because we just know, you know what I mean? That,
you know, you could get in trouble. Right.
So don't do the sh don't tell stories, but you're in your own private home.
Right. Or you're doing some sort of entertainment,
like just like stand up comedy for us. I just want to have this right.
When you're watching anyone's act from bill bird to Sebastian or
whoever it might be. Right. It's all.
Based on.
Some nibble of truth,
but it's all exaggerated for entertainment. Right. I mean,
I would love to do an episode where somebody asked me if,
if something is utterly true of the stories that I've told,
because I've done thousands of hours of talking, you know what I mean? And, um,
and I would have to say there's a lot of things like the audition that I had
for, um, Godzilla is true. That actually happened.
And that's pretty much, did you really.
Go hi. Yes. Oh, wow.
No, but so that, those things are true. Right.
But there's so many other things that, you know, I mean, you know.
Or when it comes to like this poor guy, like fearing for his job and whatnot,
I don't know, man.
I don't even know where I stand because I do like to crack jokes like that with
like my friends and I have gotten in trouble for.
If your, if your boss tries to contact HR to say, like,
I heard that he was saying something about docking with midgets,
like the boss is kind of dumb. We never talked about Trump. We don't have to,
well, that's the end of our show guys. Uh.
He's back in the white house. Oh my God. Are we really going to do this?
Just a little bit? Just a little bit, just a little bit, just a little bit.
Yeah.